here's a voicemail that came in our
voicemail number is a two one nine two
david p a voicemail about masks orders
let's take a listen to it
david um i wanted to see what your
thoughts were with mandatory masks
orders just in general a few cities have
started enacting them and i was curious
if we should see that at the state level
and what kind of punishments should be
levied assuming people violated them
okay
so first let's talk about the legal
basis there is a legal basis for masks
orders no question about it
remember that whole states rights power
of the states thing that a lot of
republicans like to talk about this
falls under that a federal nationwide
mask order from the federal government
would actually be legally dubious state
and local governments have pretty broad
authority particularly during a public
health emergency so I believe that the
legal case for a statewide or citywide
mask order is not legally problematic
inside of businesses businesses remember
Republicans wanted this stuff businesses
have broad authority within their
businesses and they can also say you've
gotta wear a mask to be in my business
but I feel like it's the wrong focus the
reality is I don't think this should
come down to legality it comes down to a
legal question because so many people
just don't want to wear a mask we know
they're very very effective what this
should come down to is doing the right
thing because we want to fix this and we
want to take care of the people around
us and we want to take care of our
communities so if you make this a legal
argument I believe that cities and
states are very very comfortably able to
legally put in place mask orders I hate
that it's even a question we should be
doing it because it's just the right
thing to do we've got a great bonus show
today we will talk about what was a
closer than expected race in the
Kentucky Republican Senate Amy McGrath
officially winning against Charles
Booker we will talk about that we will
talk about the South Pole warming at
three times the global average over the
last 30 years horrifying stuff and we
will also discuss Mississippi
dropping its confederate themed flag all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show don't miss it
become a member at join pakman.com to
get instant access